democracy works best when its voting
system is free fair and accessible to
all eligible voters right the voter
participation in this year's midterm
elections might not be as easy as it
should be
here are three voting laws that might
keep some Americans from the polls more
states than ever are now requiring
voters to show a form of photo ID when
casting their ballots so what's the big
deal well more than one in ten US
citizens don't actually have one this
includes 25 percent of African Americans
20 percent of 18 to 29 year olds and
low-income voters groups that
traditionally vote Democratic supporters
of voter ID laws say that they prevent
voter fraud except that voter fraud is
extremely rare between 2000 and 2014
there were 31 incidents of voter fraud
out of 1 billion ballots cast and don't
mess with Texas because the Supreme
Court recently sided with the state's
lawmakers to enact voter ID laws in this
midterm election Texans now have to
present one of seven eligible IDs in
order to cast their vote and while a gun
permit is considered an official ID a
university ID is not and Texas isn't
alone a total of 31 states require IDs
at the polls this year early voting is
already underway except that in some
states it's not all that easy voting
early allows a person to cast a ballot
on a day and time that doesn't get in
the way of things like work or childcare
but in states like Wisconsin politicians
are fighting to reduce or even eliminate
early voting the state's Republican
Governor Scott Walker recently cut
weekend voting and nighttime voting
backers of Walkersville say that rural
counties don't need weekend voting so
why should city folks be able to vote
early when they can't but here's
something they don't mention voters in
Wisconsin's biggest cities Milwaukee and
Madison are disproportionately people of
color and Governor Walker is also in a
tight gubernatorial race where the
outcome will largely be determined by
how many people come out to vote and
just to put early voting in perspective
in the two
all presidential election 1/3 of voters
cast a ballot before Election Day oh and
african-americans are 26 times more
likely to vote early and then there's
same-day registration something offered
in a small number of states it allows
folks to register and vote on the same
day not only is it super convenient for
people that have moved around a lot most
commonly low income folks and young
adults it's also increased voter turnout
particularly among people of color is it
any surprise then that some states have
ended same-day registration take North
Carolina for example one of the most
important battleground states in the
country during the 2008 presidential
election 36% of same-day registration
voters were African American even though
they represented 20 percent of eligible
voters Obama won the state by a small
margin and now with a closed Senate race
whose outcome could determine which
party controls the Senate as a whole it
seems every vote in North Carolina will
count so those are just a few examples
of how voter restriction laws are
playing out across the country so is
American democracy at its best if some
voters can't even cast their ballot want
more download the aj+ mobile app and
join the conversation
available in your app store now